hello and welcome to Sidetrack on a very
special day we're very very happy side
Trekkers today aren't we guys
say yes very very
we have done well but we are here to
celebrate and we're gonna you know have
a little bit of fun as we reach the 20K
mark
thank you so much guys
let's we'll get into it
[Music]
we might have a very special guest in a
couple of minutes as well when they when
they arrive but um yeah we we hit 20 000
subscribers this week which um was quite
exciting we're already at twenty
thousand like 400 as well which is just
amazing
um but so we're just gonna have a fun
little video we're going to talk we're
gonna be silly we we might there might
be a few little challenges
um if anybody wants this hat by the way
off straight off my head
start begging and I will send it
anywhere in the world so that's my
little gift to you I have yeah
anywhere in the world I will send it
um
I will literally just throw it at you
and so yeah start begging in the chat if
you want my hat but um I was going to do
a really cool giveaway for the 20K and
then we hit it too soon it hasn't come
on
so 25k I've got a very cool giveaway for
everybody but we will have to do it then
we just had such a good month
we had such a good month it's just we
hit 20K too soon but I'm not gonna
complain yeah guys how are you Dylan how
are you guys
good
super well I finished Target sg1 for the
first time last night so I'm I'm a happy
camper right now I think sad a little
bit but a happy camper oh no man that's
that's more exciting than in 20K man
um
I went old school t-shirt with this
evening by the way this is the first
Sidetrack logo from 18 months ago when
we first started and when I was all on
my own and nobody else to talk to me I
had this is my design and then Matt game
one that can actually do designs
um
yeah please otherwise says I need to
cover my balding head Adam that's pretty
baggy I like that that's that's pretty
biggie
um you're winning at the moment
yeah morning Jess I will say hello to
everyone I don't normally just focus on
things I see Mr sci-fi just posted any
Spielberg time travel TV movie that
almost nobody today has ever seen
okay
um Bob just the best random messages
there's Mr sci-fi because that was that
was
is that another YouTube channel I don't
know I don't care
I originally named my other channel Mr
sci-fi and then realized it was taken
I'm wondering if it's the same person
that would make sense
we have a special guest so I stole this
person
100 stolen my mate Steve who has another
Channel called stranger things stranger
times
um and he goes mudlocking he had to
explain to me what mudlocking is is
basically where you go where there's
rubbish and you get rubbish and you some
of it's not rubbish
UFOs and things when I used to do the
UFO Channel I used to talk to him and
then all of a sudden I noticed his
Facebook Channel had like loads and
loads of people on it and I was like
what
chalice how he did that
Shelly
Shelly's Frozen oh no
it's black and white
it's like nine o'clock in the morning
there and she's in Canada
we'll give her a second but she has
she's basically took us from having a
couple of hundred subscribers
she'll be back tonight so like nearly 2
000 people on Facebook that follow us
now and it's all done Shelly
um nothing I've done it's just down to
that absolute Legend So hopefully we'll
get back
Carrie thank you so much leave a comment
after the show because you're gonna go
patreon please go to patreon that would
be lovely
um that helps this Channel and yeah like
subscribe do all that business so oh
excuse me Diet Coke never good
um before we get started
we have to have a solemn moment
we have to put our hands together and
close our eyes and send a little prayer
to our stormy bear because he cannot be
with us today
so
um
so I can't remember my um holy thingy
can you remember it Matt are you
watching Heaven my Holy Father
and and all that stuff please please let
stormy get a different shift pattern so
he can return to Sidetrack he apparently
needs to be on the first shift plan so
if we can all send our prayers
to our stormy bear
to bring him back to us safely
um and get him off the shift pattern
that means he keeps working Sundays
let's try this again hi track pray for
us holy patrons pray for us
no we can't see you Shelley
we're praying to Richard Branson
oh Shelly Shelly Shelly yeah we have to
approach Richard Branson I'll see if she
moves oh no she moved then Canadian
internet is rubbish
um is that that's not the problem
just wave so hello
can you hear me
Canadian what's wrong with Canadian
Wi-Fi chef
[Laughter]
uh we still wanted to talk to Charlene
and we're not going to be able to I
don't think and she's gone again but oh
well never mind
um yay Shelly Shelly's gonna try again
we'll see if we can take anything
um
but we love Shelly she's amazing she
works so hard for our Channel and she
gets nothing out of it and she works
really hard for a couple for lots of a
few other people's channels to be honest
and she gets another family and she's an
absolute Legend and we love her very
very much so let's see if she reappears
um but guys so how have you been doing
what you've been watching this week
anything good where were you when we hit
20 000 I was in bed how about you guys I
was in bed when it happened I I went to
bed and we were I think about
50 maybe 40 away and I think I messaged
you and then the next morning I woke up
and went way past it we were like 100
over first time I'd I'd even bothered
looking at my phone yeah
I think I was eating a meal watching sg1
so let's do this
perfect absolutely perfect yeah
um yeah I was I was in bed but then um
oh we're gonna try one more time should
we try one more time with Shelley third
time's a charm you know the Canuck him
she hasn't appeared yet but wishes their
boxes just appeared
um but we'll try one more time Sean
hello Shelly
can you hear us all the way in Canuck
country
we saw her blink blink twice if there's
somebody there and you're scared
do we need to send the mounties hello
guys
we can hear you for like a second and
then you've gone
Shirley while you if you can hear me
anyway thank you so much for all your
help with the channel you've been an
absolutely brilliant Side Track mommy
really and we love you very much for it
so um just give everybody away so that
we all know who Shelly is and go over to
Facebook Shelley does all the work on
there
there's a link in the description to it
um
yeah I can't do anything other than that
she's amazing thank you the 12 Monkeys
are connecting they've attacked Canada
oh God the surely live in dog River I
don't know that's a Canadian thing
probably but never mind
um
she's still she's still there I don't
know whether to she just gives you
that's anyway let's move on so um yeah
unfortunately stormy can't be with us
today but um
hopefully he'll hear her prayers and
he'll be returning with us soon so he's
here in spirit and through storm bear
Spirit yeah he sent me a message and it
just said please God get me off this
shift pattern and I was like okay I'll
go with that
so yeah have you guys watched anything
good this week
I have started to watch The Walking Dead
I've never watched it but I I'd watched
The Last of Us and I loved it and I
thought what else can I watch that has
zombies in it and I've been playing
daisy a lot which is very zombie
zombie-ish
um so yeah I convinced the missus we
started watching it and I'm loving it so
far I think I'm like four episodes in
yeah it's really good he talked stormy
about that he loves it he adores Walking
Dead did you ever watch I mean did you
ever play the The Last of Us video game
I didn't play a lot of it but um I have
played it so you never finished it or
anything
no okay because I watched the show and
then we played the game I've got it on
my PlayStation
um
it's not installed now so I've just
changed to an SSD but I probably will
reinstall it at some point
that's the game I always go back to I've
put more time in that game than any
other game but I I guess what I'm
wondering is
do you enjoy so far the first season of
The Walking Dead or the last of us more
because I gotta go The Walking Dead
honestly I really enjoy The Last of Us
each episode I think is a better episode
but as a whole and like including the
world they're in like the last of us
just didn't make sense for the world
they're in there would be so many more
clickers around every corner it didn't
feel like they were legitimately
endangered the sheer amount of zombies
in The Walking Dead in the second
episode
it it feels right anything you ever saw
in in The Last of Us and yeah I'm like I
I don't know if I want to say I like The
Walking Dead more yet because I haven't
watched
too much of it
but I think in terms of scope and in
terms of
like
where they can go with it it's going to
be I think maybe bigger than the last of
us ever yeah
yes I think it's fair to say I was very
surprised to find out there's 11 seasons
of it and then there's Fear The Walking
Dead which has like another 10 Seasons
or something as well yeah
you're good for a little while yes
that's the dream
I think after cinema this week and I
watched a brilliant sci-fi movie because
it's not based on any sort of reality uh
John Wick 4.
um it's brilliant uh I actually did
Jenny enjoy it but somebody said figures
this is better than the first one and I
wanted to throw him down and punch him
in the face repeatedly of course it's
bloody knot people keep saying it's the
best it's nice and it's great it is good
thing which is the Sci-Fi but yeah for
all these cars still going around and
everyone's shooting guns and maybe it's
just because any other place in the
world actually this would be completely
unbelievable but it's in France for the
French people and they just kept driving
well that's after falling off of like
multiple story buildings and like a slew
of other things this guy just survives
oh he just bounces his his bones are
made out of
um a rubber or something like the one
point he falls like four stories just on
that bus and just when he's John Wick
search it just takes him longer to get
up
it just it doesn't actually like go oh
I've broken it it's just like oh that
really really hurt I should be dead
it'll take me
the bulletproof suit got it you know
something like that I don't know that
that's about what they chalk it up to
the bulletproof suit is fine right but
the impact would still break all of your
bones
um but you know I was like yeah okay
um it's it's I love the first John Wick
it was really based on it was a really
really brilliant movie and it just got
more ridiculous but they're starting to
get towards sort of like Fast and
Furious silly whereas if you're watching
it going that's not how science works
but that I'm pretty sure that's not how
gravity Works John Wick in space
I still have funny I should say good
meme the other week um and it said um it
was like Fast and Furious one and it was
them racing cars fast and furious two
and it was then like with them in space
or nine sorry them in space and then at
fast and a few is 20 and it just had
like um Star Wars
do you remember they were legitimately
considering a crossover between Fast and
Furious and Jurassic Park
which at this point like all right well
yeah no no Universal is possibly still
considering this
they're two big franchises put them
together right they could be in the same
world technically right and honestly
mate I wouldn't
I'm gonna do a video this week for the
sides Channel and it's everything I've
learned about like the movie industry in
the last 18 months while doing this and
um and thank you much Kerry amazing
um so happy I'm part of this awesome
Channel face red heart shape face red
heart shape face it's an emoji it
doesn't show up on comments
what the [__] is she carries lost her
mind
thank you Kerry that's so sweet
um
I always prefer The Chronicles of
Riddick
because I still have my favorite I love
all the Riddick stuff
I love pitch black and it came out it
was amazing I think Riddick was
basically just a remake of pitch black
it was very similar the the formula for
the story something Chronicles really
stands out but the Chronicles Relic is
the one that bombed and everyone says oh
let's hope they don't do that again I'm
like yeah no do you think it was amazing
that was my favorite oh love that's the
thing I remember just I and both of
those movies I I remember from my
childhood a lot the teacup killing in
the first one and all the way to
Chronicles it's just all great
yeah yeah that's cool I like those dogs
and the Chronicles Riddick the uh the
evil dogs but yeah Riddick says well
we're getting the fourth one uh let's
see what they do with it so
um I should do a video on that really at
some point the Chronicles already
deserves more love
than it gets they do
it's just a proper sci-fi movie where I
do the two Monster films really
Chronicles Rick is a sci-fi movie yeah
I think it's what's ridiculous I only
watch it once
sorry Matt you look like you're gonna
say something then
I was saying I was thinking about uh
something else I've watched this week
but it wasn't sci-fi
I watched a new Matilda musical that's
actually pretty good yeah it looks good
yeah what should we were kids yesterday
really enjoyed it
that was a good kids movie actually
um what did I watch yesterday
in the theater anyway
um I watched um the new shazam movie ah
I quite enjoyed it it was right yes
right
um a bit fun don't take it too seriously
I wonder the critics I think they're
expecting it's like oscar-winning acting
or something I'm like no I can't dance
right well the first one was
I think just so much better the film
than anyone expected it to be the second
one is just kind of
TQ Batman's about three or four weeks
early on that one but hey three or four
weeks we're gonna quote you on it we
gotta work hard the next couple weeks
and we haven't done too badly this last
month we were only 3 000 subscribers so
uh we haven't done much uh so Kerry's
just got her mug Shelly bought her a mug
bless her
um
well yeah
um and what did I watch yesterday
um so what's John Wick for
um
Dungeons and Dragons I saw it turns into
dragons
so good it's the funniest thing that's
been in theaters this year so far and
cocaine bear is still absolutely
hilarious but Dungeons and Dragons is
the funniest thing in the theater so far
it's really funny it's well acted the
story is brilliant it's just great and
I'd love to do it again with the cage
and all the characters from the cartoon
are in there the kid with the horns and
everything I nearly got out my channel I
was like yeah
I I was I mean you know I I had a little
Greenery before going into the Dungeons
and Dragons film of course so the entire
fat Dragon Aspect of that movie I was
just I I was falling out of my chair it
was it was great
it was funny uh man okay we've got we
have stormy back we have her back in
Shelly one more time let's try
I'm starting to think Canada hasn't got
a lot of Technology
we can hear your stuff Shelly
try to speak
oh that's so disappointing
never mind it's not working it's not
working Shannon
we'll give in but we will have you back
another time we'll have her back another
time when Canada turns the Wi-Fi on
um but now she's a legend we love her so
much
um
yep 25k we'll have her in for 25k plan
watching D Space Nine who's with him I
mean I watched Deep Space Nine last year
absolutely adored it and I'm so glad I
did for the um for Picard series and
three because you really need to watch
it to understand what the hell is going
on in Picard season 3
um I think it's the best Star Trek
series as well it's my favorite which is
a very controversial subject and neither
of you give a [__] about Star Trek
stormy was here he'd be with me now
see my favorite Star Trek series is
Stargate Universe and I haven't even
seen either one yet
the universe
fair enough universe is the best
have you got Atlanta you're gonna watch
Atlantis now then Harris oh yeah I I see
just because I was like I gotta finish
sg1 like I don't care if the quality is
a little worse like I'm just at this
point mentally I have to finish this so
I did it now I was going back and forth
episode episode between the two shows
but
is finished
I was just finished the 10 seasons so
um what is the name of the girl Carter
saved
uh the the young girl or like John
Lennar the the Cassie Cassie okay
Cassandra but near enough
what varies about the Stargate address
to be dialed to get to Earth from planet
to planet
so you're on a different planet what do
you change
it
the Poo the point of origin yes oh what
Chevron is the point of origin seven
yeah well done Matthew actually no
that's that's incorrect because if it's
innate if it's done right
G1
at the end of the series
has Matt watched Firefly yet no
I don't know where it is where is it
Disney Disney yeah is it on Disney so
yeah
okay I'll watch it which goddess was
both sister and wife to Osiris
uh uh oh oh uh it's it's worth right
no no is it another age what am I think
Isis Isis Isis ah well done I wouldn't
have got that in a minute the next
letter in the alphabet I was close yeah
should we quiz you instead no finish the
quote but we also saved your little
butts from the replicators
go on there
oh I don't even hear the question I was
reading what Shelly was saying
I'm excited oh oh that was what she um
just that that little last bit there's
for you Matt
the happiest thing that she wanted to do
was to come on and just shell to tell
you to your face to shut up
but I'll do it for you Shelly don't you
worry I have got you covered go on the
mat you reckon you can you're gonna take
me down gonna test me on Stargate
welcome to the Stargate sg1 quiz
we have our contestants we have Jay and
Harris oh oh okay I'm here I want my my
Wi-Fi slowing down now one second
come on back come on back here we go I'm
back that theme tune killed your Wi-Fi
[Laughter]
at one point there is ten questions the
person with the most points at the end
will win the coveted title of sg1 King
okay old fart versus newbie the new
gloves got this it's it's rookie rookie
luck over here come on
Sally want some contestants are you
ready for my cap at the moment two
people fighting over my cap
you need to you need to beg beg Adam
versus Shelley at the moment Adam versus
Shelly at the moment
oh you're both ready
I'm ready hit me question number one
how long can a wormhole stay open
normally
13 minutes I already started 38 minutes
that's correct point to Jay
new rule you have to let me finish the
question before you answer
I can't put in yeah where are buzzers we
need buzzers we'll make buzzing noises
and really just throw all the sound off
yeah yeah just go
question number two yeah the leader of
sg9 set himself up as a God on a
primitive primitive Planet what was the
name of the episode
uh
it was something really interesting
the Commandment
It's the episode last commandment first
Commandments
I'll give it to you it's the first
commandment
I'm good at this one okay
I got eight more to catch up don't worry
question number three
Vala maldaran was the host to a gold
symbiote much like Scara was to chlorel
what was the name of the garage her body
and uh it's correct or
um
there it is there it is
[Music]
finish season 10. technically this
morning
I was hoping
the members of SG-1 meeting Advanced
race called The Knocks
what is the name of the young boy in the
group that they met
[Music]
fruit
you're just getting colder now you're
leaning more towards wrong now
are you
no no
it was nephreyu so I got the new right
we can give you that I think
send it to an AI they'll come up with me
for you
I don't know
question number five
who is the first member of sg1 to meet
Jennifer Haley
is it not Sam
it is but you didn't buzz in
uh
[Laughter]
just plugged in and stole it there real
quick shoot
hey question number six you might not
get this one because I didn't know this
what season seven episode did Amanda
Tapping direct and Michael Shanks right
what was the name of the episode
oh you've got options there though you
know you have no options I think I'll
know it when I hear it as well there's
no options on this one
I purposely took ones without options
I don't have episode names
I'm amazed I got that first one to be
honest
that was good um
remember the episode
no mate I don't know that one
no the episode was called
Resurrection
one of the team directed or wrote Heroes
I didn't answer it was it was
Christopher Judge involved in that one
let's have a look in a minute
Maybe
there we go
okay question seven yes and you don't
have to be a Stargate fan to get this
one
which Egyptian goddess is the daughter
of Ra
it is
[Music]
buzzers
is anybody keeping score
yep okay okay so at the minute you've
got one two three four you're on four
Harris is on two oh okay I got this you
get two more I'm screwed but I have
three questions remaining so question
eight
you can still steal Harris come on
listen closely to the question
and then give me uh and then buzz in and
give me your answer so this former US
Air Force officer was responsible for
operating a rogue nid cell that acquired
alien technology by any means necessary
I was eventually arrested and convicted
of treason however due to extenuating
circumstances he was he managed to elude
capture by the authorities
who is he uh Mabel
I'm out
now we can still draw coming no no he's
angry but I just wanted I just want to
really press home my victory over the
young one
question number nine is what happened to
Jack's son and for bonus points what was
his name
he went to school
um
it's his middle name they allude to
Cameron Mitchell actually being Jack's
son in the 10th season so he leads SG-1
now he just goes to school we don't see
him he goes to school the last episode
is like he's talking about oh no we see
him again we saw him again
we do we see him again don't we
it's interesting to go to school I can't
believe you didn't get this this was two
easy points
what happened to Jack's son Jackson
killed himself accidentally shot himself
and his name was Charlie Charlie
no no no that wasn't his son that was
his clone
oh so silly everybody in the chat name
if only I was looking in the chat
I'm using y'all more next time
stupid boy okay final question
Vala reappears uh pregnant at the end of
season nine but who is the father
tell me
all right
well yeah it's technically the all right
it's just an Immaculate right it was an
Immaculate Conception but she was
actually pregnant that's why they wrote
him
um but yeah she was um
yeah Immaculate Conception
after that uh Jay has won
that's this is me putting my
metaphorical clown on
this is
which I believe is going to Young
Shelley I think they have agreed in the
chat because I think Shelley threatened
Adam
and there's a little bit of start with
bullying going on and Adam gave him
really really quickly so
um
that's one way to say
Adam come back on for the 25k where
there will be a giveaway and um you will
like it okay at some point during the
the rest of this show
I'm gonna ask I'm gonna find another
question I'm gonna say it at some random
point and the first one who gets it
right
Winner Takes It All Is winner
winner 100.
but
we'll see I'll seed until until the
winner takes off question
okay then all right now
um
yeah I don't know I I don't actually
know what else to talk about today
because I haven't planned anything I'm
just so excited about doing this
and then
but I don't know what what you guys what
are you guys thinking what you want to
talk about or get in the comments what
do you guys want to talk about
somebody actually talk about Stargate
all day long yeah
we could we could and you know we're
gonna do as well uh in SGU there you go
mark an SGU do you think Rush knew that
Destiny was powered by stars when he
elected to stay on board I remember
originally thinking yesterday a decade
ago but after last night's re-watch I'm
thinking no
um it had to be it's been a while since
I watched all of SGU but it had to sort
of like fly through the chronosphere
didn't it of the Sun and and recharged
which thing guys did he know I I I did
originally think that he knew
um because he would have surmised that
the the ship needed to get power somehow
and the stars are the only thing in the
Galaxy or the universe that are going to
be constant to get power from so I
always assumed he would think that but
I don't know he doesn't really seem to
give it away that he knows and actually
he seems quiet
scared
in a way
if I remember that right
I I think it's a guess
I think he doesn't know my internet's
slow again
um
um I think he would definitely have
assumed Destiny had some sort of shields
to save them from you know being burnt
alive in the in the
Stars again Horizon Corona sphere
whatever you want to call it
but I don't know if he uh necessarily
thought it and it powered the ships
maybe he didn't know I say he
he came up with some well
he spent enough time thinking about it
but he can't have known Kenny he can't
have known
he must have suspected and took a risk
and it took him a long time to unlock
the the master code to even get onto the
bridge
and that happened way after
um they plowed into the sun
I can try I need to do a contrite [__]
that's genius Bob oh that really is come
try her
control
well done
um
I like those Tiki Batman stuffley
Academy would be the best Star Trek show
ever and discuss yeah I know you guys
don't give a crap about Star Trek but it
won't be it'll be awful please God don't
make me watch it
I'm gonna have to watch it because I do
a side track Sci-fi channel and I'm
gonna have to watch Star Trek 90210 with
a bunch of 16 year olds running around
I've got two 14 year olds in this house
by then they'll be 16. I'm gonna end up
killing somebody and it'll be Star
Trek's fault and that's what I'm going
to have in my defense
so if you guys didn't know they're going
to do a Starfleet Academy TV show based
in the 32nd Century it's going to be a
bunch of 16 year old hormonal kids with
phases that won't go wrong
uh is that going to show your one or is
that different
no Michelle yo is supposedly going to do
section 31 which is different
and we'll possibly follow on from Picard
to do it but I did hear a rumor and it
is very much a rumor that they've got
Michelle Dio to do it and that's why
Alex kurtzman has been allowed to do
Stafford Academy because they weren't
necessarily gonna but now he is
interesting practice to play sg1 if it
all goes ahead oh man I'm going slogan I
might go slow on your end
you look fine for me
oh my mind
do you have any actors in mind to play
the SG on team if it goes ahead there's
something going on with Jay now
I'll come back in a second
I mean you're out of sync that's that's
about it yeah I don't know what's going
on I just saw Tiger Claws going at the
air I was wondering what was happening
that was me messing around I'll just
change in one
I have more than one
but honestly I like the mouse teller
idea
I think Miles Teller really would be
good
see I think they should try and bring
back the P the the Young
people from Stargate originally so
you've got Cass Sandra you've got Young
Jack you've got
uh Haley look at that Haley
she'd be cool right bring him but bring
those into the fold maybe not
necessarily
sg1 but
you know be be pivotal figures in the
show maybe
um Cassie could be the new the new
doctor
Haley would obviously be the new Sam
because she's like brilliantly clever
um
yeah probably would be Jacqueline here
I had um Haley as a captain of um of a
BC
um 306 when I did
I started to write a story which I must
get back to
um because I've got time right now I
have Mondays off thank you side trackers
you you're a Legend
um so I might I might do that again but
yeah I had her as Captain of um as a
Starship
because last time we saw her she was
aboard the Hammond
so I thought well she might have got
promoted by now
so um but yeah I like I I quite like
that I think I don't I don't know about
actors off top of my head because I mean
I don't want to see in a way I don't
want a bunch of actors I know
I want actors that I know from something
I go I like him but I don't you don't
necessarily know their names you know
that sort of that sort of level
um and because like David Hewlett to me
I'd seen him in other stuff but I never
didn't know his name and then I still
remember K and sg1 I was like I love
that guy
um you know I want that sort of actor so
and an actor that they can get without
spending a fortune and it's just a good
character they'll almost certainly have
to be British and because you Americans
can't act I mean we're way better at it
um
I'll just I'll just wait for Harris to
come I think we should start a campaign
of Harris to appear in Stargate I was
just about to say Hey you wanted some
crazy ass character actor out I got you
any day Amazon MGM imagine the leaks
we'd get if Harris was in Stargate right
we have we have this game we have come
back and Harris who's in the show
hire me and we can control the leagues
Amazon we can we can control the leaks
okay control them to give them to me
well that's that's not exactly what
point
of course
yeah Jack Brennan if he doesn't get the
bond roll would be brilliant I love Jack
Banner
um again British actor uh am I getting
him the wrong way around
Daniel Day-Lewis is all I have to say
about this statement you said earlier
Lewis he was Irish isn't it is he really
I thought he was American
searching Daniel Day Lewis
Danielle oh damn he is UK I lied okay
then I'm saying Meryl Streep
going back on it
going back on it where's Mill Street
from
he's from the US I know that she's like
I think like the Northeast is American
she was born in Canada not sure
Shelley still wins at the end of the day
um there's always exceptions to the rule
but generally speaking if an American's
funny he's Canadian
and if they can act really well they're
British
so generally speaking
but then I got to say Jack Nicholson
Robin Williams no Jack Nicholson just
plays Jack Nicholson
for the most part it's always great it's
old blues are brilliant attack so he's
not he's just brilliant it's just gone
well that's just I don't know if he's in
this I love Jeff Goldblum but he's not
in the same sentences Nicholson at least
can be put in the same sentence as Day
Lewis
yeah okay love me some gold blue no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
no Daniel J Lewis is a properly
brilliant actor who who is completely
different in every role Jack Nicholas is
a brilliant actor who is Jack Nicholas
in every role
who
shot Jack Nicholson
Nicholas the golfer Jack Nicholson
um oh I love him don't get me wrong and
he's got a mean back swing
Day Lewis is always the the the
Juggernaut there
but Nicholson is in the same songs
because of the roles do you know who you
should have gone for for brilliant
American actor who is freaky and is
different in everything uh Justin
Hoffman
where he's from
oh no he's from the U.S America yeah
he's I honestly I understand sometimes
you get these American these these great
actors and then there you can you forget
it's him
if you watch even watch hook
right and you forget that's Justin
Hoffman it looks nothing like him either
no it's amazing
um and then you watch Tootsie and he's
like Jesus God is this amazing creamer
versus Kramer chocolate male Street
just phenomenal actor he's absolutely
amazing
um screw the Brits and the Yanks get an
Australian
neighbors that's quite nice but there's
loads of Australian actors in that job
they're fun yeah
um I I'd go with you know Brad Pitt is a
great actor Again Brad Pitt but
um Leonardo DiCaprio though
and if we want to go if we I'll change
my three words I screwed up with Day
Lewis of course but how about Robert De
Niro can I use that one
except he plays the same gangster over
and over as well but
that's my to narrow impression
my best mate's dad looks exactly like
him and my best mate looks like Patrick
Swayze so
what kind of love child thing happened
there
um generalization did say Keanu Reeves
and I think he must be I think he's
joking I love Keanu he's I love piano
win an Oscars anytime soon you know he's
he's probably the nicest guy in acting
um but he's not a great Act
um but he's good
Jack Nicholson his eyes are so creepy
um love Canada Christopher Walken though
he's another actor that just plays
Christopher Walken but he does it so
well he he plays different characters
and they feel like different characters
please please say one of you can you
hear us walking accent
I can't do a Christmas okay
I can't [__] do it
oh imagine Christopher Walken is a Gould
it would be I'd love it Java green
I I loved him in Sleepy Hollow there's a
bad guy he's freaking incredible I was
just like what I'm moving
um
I'd love to see him as a bad guy that'd
be awesome
is the general
yeah just in charge uh what What's the
movie I can't think of it I should know
it off the top of my head where they're
about to shoot him and he's just like
do it like like they're like begged for
your life he's like no
I I can't think of what it is they're in
the middle of the road but it's just the
funniest scene ever staying with
Christopher Walken and the guy from
speeds that's like that in um True
Romance that's absolutely brilliant and
the guys about they're about to kill him
and he basically just because he knows
he's got to protect his son so we're
basically just insults them like crazy
until they shoot them in their head I'm
Jim Carrey's Canadian as well so you're
dissing your own your own family there
pretty much
um but so Kerry Kerry comes to America
now we we've claimed Carrie and Gosling
they're Americans at this point yeah
like I said yeah Chris Pine always plays
the same actor he's the same character
over and over again and regardless of I
think but what's so good in Dungeons and
Dragons Kiefer Sutherland he's done
everything else oh slow down again
Kiefer Sutherland why not it should be
the next general
that'd be great Kiefer Sutherland is
awesome
yeah he's a brilliant actor my son has
just found
um designated Survivor
I never watched it it always looked
great
the first season is phenomenal after
that don't bother after watching it
after that just watch the first season
um but it's it's great it's so clever
such a clever storyline stole it from
The West Wing completely but it's really
fun
my favorite Kiefer Sutherlands always
and I'm just such a big fan of the
movies but Young Guns one and two I I
love Young Guns
still good it's the first one in
particular Charlie Sheen yeah and
um Emilio Estevez in the movie as well
together Lou Diamond Phillips makes that
movie for me
the first one's better than the second
one oh yeah the second one I I love
because I love the first one the first
one I genuinely just adore
um
let me read that right so I had a true
or false question known as high school
true or false much to do about nothing
proves that Cannery is a great actor the
president is false everyone got that
right is he in yeah and he he acts well
you just can't take him seriously
because of his voice
I don't like him in anything he's not a
good actor he's a brilliant he's just
one of those nice actors that Everyone
likes but
um I'm sorry guys my answer is terrible
today
but anyway
um so what we what we planning for
have you gotten any ideas about what
you're doing in shows coming up that you
want to do
anyway it is and guys get into the
comments again is there anything you
want to see us talking about throw in
the comments or if you've got any
questions you want to ask us while we're
still on but we'll be on for another 20
minutes or so if you've got any
questions throw them in Jeremy Renner
has no Chin
he's got no Chin at all
um he is a great actor though brilliant
architect but he's got you
um yeah he's recovering didn't he just
like post a picture or something the
last week or two that he's up in Adam
again he's doing a little video
good good
very happy little boy so he I mean he
was nearly killed as well so
right there's another actually doing a
big trouble a little have you seen a Big
Trouble in Little China with Kurt
Russell yeah
yeah of course you have as Matt Matthew
[Music]
Firefly big trouble little challenge the
little China's on Netflix at the moment
I think it's definitely on one of them
anyway I definitely watch Firefly right
watch Firefly big trouble little China
is abdominal it's such a good movie and
they're remaking it
and um some idiots gonna remake it it's
just like no some films don't need
remains definitely one of them it's not
even like really outdated or anything
like it's
it still stands fine yeah
and um I just don't I don't get the
thinking and the other thing is if you
did like one with Kurt Russell and he's
an old guy maybe all right fine
um they're doing Escape From New York
again as well no because I was just
about to say if Matt hasn't seen Big
Trouble in Little China watch that and
then just drink a beer or two and watch
Escape from New York and escape from L.A
or something right after but um if I
think I'm right in thinking that
actually Kurt Russell is going to be
snake again in the new escape and it's
like escape from California or something
um
yeah
that may be doable if they do it like
well I mean there have been some good
Legacy things like like Top Gun stuff
recently but but I mean
where's the interest and and you got to
have a good script kind of like what we
were saying about Legally Blonde three
the other week who cares you know it's
like yes they're great movies and we all
love the original stuff but it's been so
long it's not like that clamoring thing
where Kurt Russell hasn't been doing
anything he's been talking about it like
one of the reasons Tom Cruise got us all
to get tickets for Maverick was
he's hammering that in and and Top Gun
is just a cultural staple that people
watch every year anyway especially in
the states
so it was kind of like a no-brainer
there but some of these Legacy stuff I
don't know where we're going with it no
neither
um to Blade Runner I do know a little
bit about that we haven't gone as far as
actors I believe because it was put on
pause
for a little bit Dave
um earlier this year
um but they've just sort of unpaused it
so the development sort of I don't know
if you know there's so much going on in
streaming services in the last few
months and a lot of them sort of like
slowed things down a little bit and this
is one of those projects that got slowed
down
it was supposed to be out this summer
and it's not going to be out now until
like probably next summer
um but
um as far as I know there's no actors
signed on to it yet
um but it is sort of back
in sort of pre-proof they've got going
again with it
um it was all put on pause but they have
got going again with it
um would you if you go see an Avenue
five I have it's just got canceled
did you ever watch
yeah right no I never saw it is
it it got really good reviews and got
really bad reviews just depending on the
season right yeah it depends I think it
depends on what you expected from it if
us British people I think we liked them
all because we it's a bit red dwarfi
um
sorry
is it a comedy yes yes
I think the first season was more comedy
in the second season they did it a
little bit more seriously but it's like
satirical so I think you either get it
or you don't
um one of the things was that the the
whole ship is like drags a big thing of
poop around it
um so basically when they flush the
toilets it flushes out because of the
gravity of the ship it sort of drags it
along but it actually causes a radiation
Shield
um and actually it's a really good
radiation shield and stuff but they
don't they start to lose they have to do
a burn or something they lose their big
poop shield and that's a big joke for
like the first season and um and it goes
on a bit but
it wasn't like for me it wasn't dramatic
enough to be a drama but it wasn't funny
enough to be a comedy
fell in between and it was a bit
it didn't quite work I I might be off
but it wasn't didn't it either came out
but it wasn't it either the answer to or
it was the answer for uh space force
when space force didn't do well for
Netflix
well I I I think it's kind of I was
gonna actually say I think it's kind of
a bit like the problem of space force
it's the same kind of thing it's pitched
the same kind of way that like say it's
it's a comedy yeah
funny yeah drama but it's not and it's
satirical but it's not really like in
your face satirical
um it's it's and and I mean particularly
space force was expensive to make for
Netflix it's really expensive and they
expected it to do so well and it just it
just didn't and I think it's because
people didn't quite get it it's like
what am I watching
and I wish Netflix would I don't know
how the company still doesn't do it but
they don't know what advertising even
means
like
it's just not on the radar
but also real quick I don't want to
derail Bob just asked that question
exactly
I have to do a movie education on
I'll do a little list
all right Tremors
look you can listen to five million
movies and like
999 995 of them I would not have seen
five yeah but you've got it I am living
one of those people if I like a film
I'll watch it
and I might watch it a couple of times
but I'll never watch I don't watch films
over and over again I don't really have
I don't watch films like I'm not a movie
person really
I like Series right guys guys get into
the comments we need to now do a list of
movies that Matthew has to watch like
like
ajs yeah you've seen Predator right
um have you seen predators
right
right that's a good one Silent Running
it's a classic
Have you listened to the new Silent
Running song
I'm not going to put that on the list
though right you've seen Die Hard
obviously
that's the greatest movie that's ever
been made no
but
you must be the only one
no you've never seen Die Hard
no with Bruce Willis
I'm aware of the film I've just never
watched is it a Christmas movie what do
you watch at Christmas
elf
you know a film that actually is about
Christmas
and die hard is a Christmas movie ho ho
ho now I have a machine gun what yes
mate you oh Die Hard is one of the
greatest movies ever freaking made
like 19 [__] sequels for a reason
it's because it's quite good
um Shelley wants to know if you've seen
Muppets from space
yeah I've seen mothers from his face
Scottish priorities down all right
I didn't hate moonfall I didn't hate it
all right it's just stupid
but it's not stupid enough to be
stupidly brilliant it's just stupid
I'll never forget being that iMac
screening with Roland Emerick and him
trying to explain the movie after we'd
all seen it and my stone self was just
sitting there just chuckling like for
three hours for the whole movie I had a
blast just because it was not it was
just dumb fun but then right after the
Whole 30 45 minute interview was just
fantastic people were really trying to
like pick it apart get sciency stuff and
my stone self was just sitting there
laughing you couldn't do the sciencey
stuff because at one point the moon
comes within about 100 meters of the
Earth
and it was oh gravity
put the SUV in sports mode
I was like great this makes so much
sense
um that's um there's a gravity wave
where the shuttle's trying to take off
and we'll use the gravity wave oh God as
like that helicopter gets launched into
the freaking giant tidal wave it's like
he could have avoided this they flew
right into a wave yeah mistakes were
good we flew into the massive wave but
Halle Berry survived
Halle Berry should always survive
Harry belly's greatest movie moment
it's easy
swordfish she's talking to Wolverine and
she puts the thing down and you see her
boobies and it's brilliant for two
reasons right
I like boobies I'm a boy I just do and
book two she got 50 grand for that scene
we got 15 grand for a 50 grand 50 000 to
go what I can wash up her boobs I'm just
like for one girl great boobs well done
for two oh you are a negotiating master
your your agent was just laughing all
the way to the bank because you don't
get what you're you don't get what
you're owed in Hollywood Rubbermaid
Burnett has a great quote you don't get
what you wrote you get what you
negotiate yeah damn right
um
just fantastic right Critters
no and then I'll give you that one
that's a bit obscure as well
no
it's quite a good film
um brilliant boobies oh no sorry
yes I've seen that one
as well
realistically though Die Hard is great
but you gotta watch Tremors trimmers is
deep yeah we want to talk about B movies
trimmers may be the VB movie like it is
it is the best beat movie ever made
honestly and it's honestly it's got good
actors in it you'll you'll know hey
who's that guy that um does all the ee
adverts over it what's his name again
Kevin Bacon Kevin Bacon that's not a
joke
it's the Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon game
which we should play one day that'll be
a good game that'll be a good video to
do we'll start with an actor we'll just
do six degrees to see if we can get to
Kevin Bacon
um that'd be a fun game so um I like
that stuff I'll tell you what we'll have
to we'll do that in a couple of weeks
we'll do the six degrees have you ever
done like the Wikipedia game where you
choose like a specific something and you
both like you have somebody next to you
and you both start and you just try to
find whoever can get to this article the
quickest or something like say choose
Jesus you got to find a way to get to
Jesus and and it's whoever if you get
six clicks nine clicks whatever it is
you start at the same article and then
you kind of like find your way out it's
so much fun it's so Random we used to
play a movie game a lot where you just
pick two movies
and you've got to connect them
and it's got to be that just actors have
appeared
you can go actors directors
um I don't think we have producers or
actors or directors and you have to
correct connect them so you have to go
okay so he was in this and but he
directed back who's in and you've got to
like do direct link and it's got to be
within six so say if you have
Tremors and Die Hard
right now Matt's not gonna be able to
play this game because he's rubbish but
you've got to connect Tremors to Die
Hard in less than six steps six steps or
less oh
so
um let me think so Kevin Bacon is
probably the easiest way to do it
because he's appeared in everything
um if we do Kevin Bacon to oh I can do
this actually I could do this really
easily I'm doing three I can do it in
three
wait hold up I think I can too I'm gonna
try to match it uh
uh trimmers to die hard right yeah
oh no uh I'm gonna need a second I'm
trying to the first thing that my mind
went to was put bacon in First Class
X-Men first Class because then that's
just a slew of people to choose from
yeah
I just I can't I can't think of uh who's
been alongside Bruce Willis then or in a
Die Hard well okay well he's uh here's
the way I did it right because I went
Bruce Willis
Expendables
Sylvester Stallone
uh Sylvester Stallone was in
um uh Guardians of the Galaxy and Kevin
Baker was in the Guardians of the Galaxy
Christmas special
Travis that's how I did it but was the
loan in the Christmas special
no but Kevin Bacon was in Guardians of
the Galaxy and then you then you connect
the Guardians of the Galaxy to Sylvester
Stallone and Guardians of the Galaxy 2
okay Expendables and then you go from
Expendables to die hard so I think
that's four actually isn't really or
maybe even five yeah
but I like it it's always easy I know
it's not always easy it's really really
good but um right and we're still
playing this game in the chat Conan the
Barbarian
I'm Gonna Save You All a lot of time
foreign
okay A Few Good Men please if you could
do some of the greatest films ever made
I've just said I'm Gonna Save You All a
lot of time Jack Nicholson
Kevin Bacon
I am aware of those people yes
they could not handle the movie that's
why you shouldn't watch it you can't you
need me in this movie you want me in
this movie
slightly
you haven't seen Shawshank
that's life-changing that's that's a oh
I've only watched Shawshank wants to be
fair
The Green Mile
I love The Green Mile
Green Mountain Shawshank I saw with
within like a week of each other the
first time I ever saw them and that that
week is just
no okay Total Recall
either one old or new now
Arnie Schwarzenegger
oh the uh yeah my uh yeah I think I have
actually if you watch the new one by the
end of it you go uh yeah from back in
the day hopefully we call that from my
brain it's so yeah I'm sure I watched
the the Arnie one years ago yeah
um
I thought one of them oh and it's gone
oh never mind we'll see when he said
Gremlins I thought what oh uh The
Goonies The Goonies okay good you're
good well don't say it like that you
haven't seen [__] die hard
of course I've seen Goonies everyone
some Goonies everyone said Die Hard
Kerry thank you so much episode to go to
patreon here oh no thank you so much I'm
still a member here though as well well
leave it's okay don't give YouTube your
money go to patreon then I get it oh we
get it
um
um but um actually I just use it to pay
for the channel but anyway yeah Andrew
seems to think I've seen the original
Stargate movie as well I haven't
that that would be the biggest like
that was a lie that one
oh he's a lie oh he's lying okay
shut up Matt
but I'm with you Carrie I'm both a
patreon member and a YouTube member
because I like the little YouTube little
stars and everything don't yeah you do
get your stuff
True Lies two lies Matthew
nice True Romance we're getting a True
Lies TV series soon
because now there'll be a TV show which
you'll watch what's it about
a spy lying and um Sylvester Stallone
of being Arnold Schwarzenegger and um
Bob Romero I'm gonna Butch your name
um
guys I don't know if you know this
is quite good
has anyone seen this film die hard it's
[__] awesome
it's almost like they should use it as
like the staple for every action movie
ever after it they should make a sequel
to this but it's set up for a sequel in
it guys it's so good
I have got that I had to be fair I've
got I've got a lot of these films I've
got them I just I don't have time to
watch films I barely have time to watch
TV series like I haven't watched
Mandalorian this week I'm just not I
don't have time
make time
make time I could make time I would be a
Time Lord
Sleepless
Sleepless if I don't sleep I just watch
Colonel Samantha Carter completely
figure out a time dilution after being
stuck 50 60 years somewhere I'm
believing you I believe in you
hmm but that's science fiction Harris
this is the real world I can't do that
anything you dream is fiction and
anything you accomplish is science the
whole history of anything
is science fiction
wise words
I have the quote on my wall over there
which is why I was kind of leaning that
way looking out I was reading off a
posted a note
that's an intelligent way
to end the um just a generalization is
just throwing a move in and I'm going to
guess
um not a bloody chance but I wonder if
he could name who's in it
do you want to know or romance in the
stone the better one that came before it
no because I've literally never heard of
it
Romance of the Stone's great
um and it's
um oh God I'm gonna forget these I'm
gonna forget the actress's name now
oh that's gonna annoy me
oh
come back to me in a minute I'll
remember who that is I've got to Google
it because I forget damn it man united
are losing
um
she's beautiful
and well while we're thinking about
movies real quick you should go to the
theater this week and go watch air when
it comes out
uh yes it was great it was great I just
saw it on a screening yesterday
oh David I should have just waited for
kathlington
yeah I do Michael douglassment I need
Michael Douglas assistant I remember
that bit I just forgot Kathleen Turner
um but yeah that's brilliant either way
I'll do anything for my favorite YouTube
channel anything
and I'm not even thinking anything
naughty there I'm just thinking that we
could get to do our housework and stuff
just just pay for a giant billboard in
in Canada
like multiple Billboards just you have
to put it in Toronto or like Banff
in Canada their internet's rubbish
that's why they need Billboards because
they don't have Internet ads
demolition though have you seen
Demolition Man the three shells
I remember my kid came to me the once
and he goes it was about 17 at the time
and I just said all predators on tonight
and he went what and he didn't leave the
house for like three days just
loads of movies
right here's your movie education sit
down
um it didn't grow up with me I had my
first son I love him to death but um I
he didn't I um anyway you know one of
those stories but anyway so when he got
my 16 I got we got a lot closer and so
he got his movie education when he was
like 16. and um and it started with
predator and we went from there weirdly
Die Hard was the second film we watched
huh
because it's weird because one of the
greatest films ever made it's perfect
anyway
um
yeah Shelly is our billboard
Shelly is our billboard that's what she
does
everywhere
only the Moose will see it well if
Shelley rides a moose in town wearing
Stargate like a gear uh I'm just saying
will have a Canadian
Town under their rules Kelly will have
to Shelly will have the Hat on just the
Hat yeah let's do that so do you want
dirty he didn't start dirty he got dirty
though oh no no no it's not a dude thing
it's a lady MacGyver thing in this
country there's a story about this lady
MacGyver who went and rode a horse
through the town and I can't remember
why but she was angry about something
um so I wasn't thinking dirty I was
thinking lady MacGyver
that's a little bit dirty but Lady
Godiva lady MacGyver MacGyver
lady what is it Godiva get down either
sorry
not lady MacGyver
and can't okay lady MacGyver was
perfectly dressed but she could take
bombs and stuff apart with like a paper
clip and sellotape she was amazing if
you broke down she just needed some
gaffer tape and some chewing gum and you
were away
um but anyway
Stargate
she'll answer it but she just won't ask
questions about it anyway guys we're
gonna say goodnight to you um we've gone
past an hour and ten we've been talking
absolute nonsense next week we will have
a plan and we will actually talk about
something sci-fi related damn it
or if we ever thought of anything we'll
play that Six Degrees of Separation game
because that sounds like lots of fun
we'll do that maybe
is Super Mario's technically sci-fi
sort of kind of no it's just video game
isn't it yeah
well it depends we'll we'll see how it
is we all got to check in our lives we
talk about whatever the hell we want to
be honest and I will occasionally get
messages from people saying
um Clayton McIver is the x-rated fish
it's good though
um
thank you again Kerry and we will try to
get our Shelley back for next time
um
I can't understand that I just got
distracted by the comments but anyway
doesn't matter thank you guys seriously
for one before we head off Harris you
get nothing out of your time for coming
here I don't know why you do it every
week it's fun thank you because you're a
legend uh Matthew I don't invite you
most weeks and you turn up anyway
um I genuinely don't know why and and it
started to piss me off a little bit so
you know
Matt you amazing we have a really really
great
um logo because you
that's literally all you've brought to
it with the logo thank you yeah yeah
sure our time speaking but now going to
like saying you don't get anything out
of it which is the amazing thing and you
still turn up every week and we still
talk absolute rubbish
um stormy as well who I Psyduck only
exists because of Stormy means stormy
talking about how we'd like to talk
about Star Trek and because I used to
have like you know guys I used to have a
mystery Channel and conspiracy Channel
and I got sick of people threatening to
kill me I'm calling me a shield so you
said let's talk about sci-fi instead and
stormy one yeah let's talk about Star
Trek and that's literally how the
channel started
um so
it was and you know just loads and loads
of fun and thank you so much thank you
so much Gary
um
oh yeah I'd forgotten about that
I I did say that didn't like are you
getting a Sidetrack tattoo at 50.
oh I can't remember
what are you gonna do
I think now Matt I think this started
with me joking Matt should get a tattoo
and then yeah and I said no because no
yeah a few already so
um I could I might get so I tell you
what I am yeah Andrew he didn't forget
no he didn't do anything let me forget
so when we hit 50k I will get
sidetracked tattooed on and a part of my
body
new beautiful Sidetrack logo Jaffa
tattooed right here
that's exactly what I'm thinking
yeah
you will officially be the Stargate
Channel
yeah I'm not sure I'm gonna go with the
logo because we keep changing the logo
every so often so I'm not sure I'm gonna
go with the logo but I will get
Sidetrack Rim across there
to be honest even if Sidetrack ended it
tomorrow
um it's been brilliant it's been such a
fun part of my life I I would I will
more than happy to get that tattooed on
me and maybe my buttocks and maybe we'll
do a video about it so we'll just have a
little just for patreon
um
you might need an only fans for that
yeah
just in memory of those good times
the the orifice comment came in too
quick after that one
brother you know the story that I've
told the story about this I don't know
about how I sent her it um once more
step through the orifice what didn't
explain it
I'm forgetting she's not a fan
oh dear anyway guys we'll we're gonna
say goodnight we're gonna say goodbye
um Harris needs his breakfast and me and
Matthew need our beds
um well I need tea to be fair and then I
need dinner yeah breakfast and then we
need to go and um Paris what look your
tunnel you leave your thing all right
there's nothing shown I'll tell you a
quick story before we go very very quick
story because I'm hungry
um I was um I'm about 19 years old right
okay I visited I was away and I came
home and visited and uh my mum had been
down to Cornwall for the weekend and I
went into the cupboard to get a cup and
there's this little block of
um like a soft Stony type stuff and I
can smell it immediately and I'm like
Mom why have you got a big lump of skunk
in the um kitchen and she but she
genuinely went how do you know what that
is
you're the one that's got it old woman
I haven't got any but I'm a 19 year old
boy I know what it smells like
so my mom went there and started
becoming a stone in her old age
hey that's okay smoke with your mom's
like one of the best things in the world
it really is
no actually it's no worse than alcohol
so but let's not get into that debate
um on a Sci-Fi channel but anyway guys
thank you so so much we will be back
next week
um I don't know about stormy but just
guys just just thank you so much
here's to the next 20 000 and
um yeah
thank you so much guys and everybody in
the chat today you're with us every
single week thank you so much
we will see you next week
[Music]